there's been quite a few rumors about
the expanse recently and it turns out it
was for a very good reason
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV a
movie channel
[Music]
so before I tell you about the quite
solid information I've had about the
expanse in the last couple of weeks I'm
going to tell you about the couple of
rumors that we've been having over the
last six to eight months really as soon
as series six ended rumors about a
season seven started because the
showrunners and everybody said that they
were going on Hiatus that the expanse
wasn't canceled it was just going on a
break
so the internet was alive and I started
hearing rumors almost immediately that
actually if Amazon chose not to push
forward with season seven of the expanse
that there are other networks lining up
to take the show now Netflix had the
first couple of seasons of the expanse
and moved away but they did apparently
Express an interest to the production
company Alcon television group that they
would be interested to take in the show
back
what I'm told was that that was never
really a goer though because Alcon
television group already had a buyer in
mind it was a buyer that they have a
very good working relationship and
somebody that they've been making movies
for for over a decade
Warner Brothers
now apparently Warner Brothers stepped
up almost immediately after season six
and this Hiatus was announced and I had
a conversation with the Alcon group they
sort of said look What's your deal with
Amazon like if you wanted to you know
move production companies and come to
our Network we would be very interested
now I told you about this seven or eight
months ago
and it's still moving forwards but why
are we hearing a lot of fresh Rumors in
the last couple of weeks by the way if
you do like the content please consider
hitting the join button and becoming a
fully fledged side tracker you can also
go to signdashtrack.com and pick
marvelous merchandise all of these
little things really help the channel
also if you're new to the channel like
subscribe hit that Bell notification and
share the video wherever the hell you
want well I have a person I speak to
that works in and around Hollywood they
have lots of really good connections and
they hear lots of really good rumors
because of the agency they work for he's
been telling me that when you are
building up towards a green light of a
new production of any new TV show you
start hearing lots of rumors now that's
partly because people are talking about
the show because production companies
and actors and writers and directors are
being approached they're being asked
would you like to work on this could you
do this could you say that so these
people whisper amongst themselves and
rumors start so just before something
gets green lit you hear lots and lots of
rumors for me I'm a massive Stargate fan
there's been a lot of rumors over the
last six months but this person I speak
to say a lot of those rumors have
stopped now that makes me very excited
because that either means they've
scrapped the whole thing which would be
terrible or it means there may be a bag
to Green Light it and we might actually
get something official from Amazon for
my favorite TV show Stargate
but
from the expanse point of view my maybe
second favorite TV show of all time
sci-fi the rumors mean that something is
being planned and something is being
worked towards but will it be for Amazon
or will it be for somebody else well I'm
told that it is not a very well kept
secret within the people that know in
that industry that actually Alcon has a
reasonably good deal with Amazon in that
it's good for alcohol they got to hold a
lot of the distribution rights and they
actually have made decent money from the
expanse but also when they did the deal
with Amazon they were not stupid and
they made sure that it was written into
the contract that if Amazon ever decided
to stop producing or to decided not to
take up an option to produce more of the
expanse that the rights reverted
straight back to Alcon and that they
could approach a different network to
produce a TV show for the future
and I'm being told that's exactly what's
happening right now Amazon have not
picked up the right to produce more of
the expanse and
very very shortly Alcon will be allowed
to speak to other production companies
I'm actually told that it is a two-year
deal that from the end of production of
season six
Amazon had two years to either pick up
or lose the rights to the expanse we're
already about halfway through that two
years so it looks like we in the next 12
months or so could hear something very
exciting one way or another about the
expanse either it coming back to Amazon
Prime or going to HBO Max
now why would Alcon go to HP on max
they have a very strong working
relationship with Warner Brothers
already
go and have a look on IMDb or Wikipedia
and look up the Alcon
um television production company
they have a very long list of movies and
TV shows that they've done Warner
Brothers they only recently ended a
10-year Motion Picture agreement with
Warner Brothers so they have a very
strong working relationship with Warner
Brothers already and as I say about
projects like Babylon 5 the expanse is a
TV show that even though it doesn't have
the massive viewing figures of Maybe
Star Trek it has an incredibly loyal fan
base a fan base that will follow the
expanse to a new streaming service and
that's the sort of thing HBO love
because they don't really care about
viewing figures as much as they care
about subscribers and if a loyal fan
base of even a million expanse followers
followed the expanse from Amazon to
Warner Brothers that would be considered
a massive Victory and well worth the
effort but what am I being told about
what is actually going on and why there
are so many rumors at the moment well
for one I was told three or four months
ago that um Thai Frank and Narin Shankar
were working towards a new TV show but
it would be a spin-off TV show and they
were trying to figure out what that TV
show would look like I was then told by
another source that actually season
seven was about to go into production
and it was actually going to go into
production in the next couple of months
I'm told by my source that um Works in
Hollywood Works in around these things
that actually that is never going to be
on the cards if filming was about to
start for a new season seven we know it
by now they don't keep these things very
well secret within the industry at least
and if that was going to happen he'd
he'd have known two or three months ago
now I was told by other sources not this
chap I've been speaking to recently
um about this spin-off idea but he
actually reiterated that to me this week
he said yes Ty Frank and Marin shankado
um showrunner are trying to create
a couple of TV seasons that would film
the gap between book six and book Seven
because if HBO Max did decide to take
this on they would want at very least a
plan for five years Five Seasons as an
absolute minimum how about now
I'm free right now now we know there is
a big gap between book sick book seven
and the books seven eight and nine are a
very different tone to what we've seen
before with the expanse
a lot happens though between book six
and book seven
so there's an awful lot of things or
really interesting things to explore
within the expanse universe
the idea that I'm being told is that HBO
Max would really love at least two or
three seasons exploring that Gap
um one of the reasons for that is the
gap between book six and seven is a
little bit confused unless you're a
hardcore fan unless you've actually read
the books it's quite hard to explain the
Gap so the more casual view might not
quite get it you've also got the other
problem that you've got plans hopefully
that are HBO Max subscribers that might
not have actually watched the expanse
before because they might not be others
and subscribers
so whatever HBO Max then produces it has
to make sense to those viewers as well I
think I'm pretty stupid don't you
foreign
so the idea being they would create two
or three seasons of something different
something that would lead into
eventually book Seven but that would
help explain and bring in new viewers as
well as satisfying the existing hardcore
fans
and then eventually going into book
seven
now I think this is actually a brilliant
idea I think it makes sense on lots and
lots of levels for the Casual View and
the hardcore view it makes sense for HBO
Max because they get to do something
that's a little bit different and
separates themselves from the Amazon
series and it's to be honest
I love book Seven it's it's a
fascinating story and everything I
really want to see it but I think there
is so much to be told in that 30-year
Gap there's so much Universe to explore
it would almost be a shame to skip over
it and what I really hate them to do is
do seven eight and nine and then do like
a prequel series or something I'd love
them to do that now and then push books
seven eight and nine back down the road
a little bit
but not too far so guys get in the
comments and tell me exactly what you
think does this sound like something
that makes sense to you is it a plan
that you can get behind or would you
rather see on Amazon because that is
still at the end of their possibility
Amazon basically have 12 months to
either trigger their clause in the
contract and make more expanse or lose
it forever
can the comments tell me exactly what
you think and if you are new to the
Channel please like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps out
and if you enjoy the content don't
forget to become a fully fledged side
tracker and hit the join Button as
always please stay safe I'll see you
next time I just wanted to say thanks
[Music]
you made some pretty stupid choices
since you've been in charge but you're
always trying to do the right things
[Music]